[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace poco el 911 recibió una llamada
esta llamada me fue enlazada a mí y me
fue lanzada a mí como parte del grupo de
voluntarios en playa del carmen que
estamos enlazados a este servicio
atendiendo las llamadas que son
tentativas de suicidio
mari a la mujer al teléfono se escucha
muy angustiada porque está viendo a su
vecina su vida en la azotea amenazando
con suicidarse
mariah sal y grita lee no lo hagas tu
vida es importante para mí le dijo maría
me responde pero si no la conozco como
lo es y eso no importa
mariah sale y le grita esto esta chica
una y otra vez hasta asegurarse que esta
chica se mantiene con vida finalmente
llega la ayuda logran bajar a la chica y
mariah nuevamente se comunica conmigo le
dijo maría felicidades hoy salvaste una
vida
mariah no se había dado cuenta la
dimensión de lo que había logrado en ese
momento
cada año se suicidan 800 mil personas en
el mundo esto no los dice la
organización mundial de la salud
quintana roo es uno de los estados con
mayor estadística de suicidio a nivel
nacional
el suicidio no distingue ni raza ni
género ni clase social
y no distingue porque tiene que ver con
una sola cosa que se llama dolor
emocional
el suicidio no es un acto de locura como
muchos creen no es un acto de valentía
ni de cobardía no puede ser evaluado
desde un lugar de juicios de juicio de
valor
el suicidio solamente un acto de dolor
emocional tú tú tú yo vamos a vivir en
un momento de nuestras vidas un alto
dolor emocional y esto es algo es como
un precio que pagamos por el simple
hecho de esta experiencia que se llama
vida
yo empecé mis estudios de sobre el tema
de suicidio cuando estudiaba la carrera
de psicología se llama de 20 años
empecé a estudiar este tema porque
perdieron la persona querida que tomó la
triste acción de quitarse la vida
para mí fue una experiencia
especialmente dolorosa especialmente
fuerte porque yo también estaba pasando
por un momento de mucho dolor emocional
en mi vida
recuerdo
en ese entonces haber escrito un poema
para una de mis clases de psicología el
poema decía así
el choque de sentimientos como las
encontradas estremece mi cuerpo
hace que vibre mi alma
estoy muriendo para renacer y aún en mi
muerte me siento más viva que nunca
morir de amor
en ese momento preciso me comprometí a
hacer toda la prevención del suicidio
que podía
en ese momento preciso decidí acompañar
al mayor número de un número de personas
que podría acompañar que había vivido
esta triste experiencia haber pedido
alguien por suicidio
escribí entonces una tesis que se llama
duelo por suicidio con una línea amiga
que muchos años después se convierte en
un libro del nombre superando el duelo
de un suicidio las experiencias en los
que se quedan
aprendí muchas cosas no solo del
suicidio sino del dolor emocional
aprendí que el dolor pasa y no pasa como
nos dicen nada más por el tiempo si no
pasa por lo que hacemos con este tiempo
tenemos que ser proactivos
me pregunto hoy en día
bueno la pregunta también para ustedes
es si todos como les digo vamos a vivir
en algún momento dado dolor emocional
quiere decir esto que todos podemos en
algún momento atentar contra nuestras
vidas
yo creo que sí
les hablaba de lo proactivo en el caso
en un caso son momentos de dolor
emocional
en el tiempo que vengo ejerciendo como
terapeuta
veo a la gente entrar a mi consultorio
con sus máscaras emocionales
que las dejan colgadas como en un
perchero imaginario en la entrada a mi
puerta
poco a poco desnudo en el alma desnudo
en el corazón me comparten su sentir me
siento increíblemente privilegiada por
ello cuando lo van haciendo veo como en
compartir sus sentimientos van sanando
hablar se vuelve una catarsis hablar es
una voz por ahí obviamente también hay
una que otra lágrima derramada
encontré una investigación de la
universidad de minnesota en eeuu que
dice algo increíble estudiaron las
lágrimas y se dieron cuenta que las
lágrimas por dolor tienen una química
diferente
qué quiere decir esto que cuando
lloramos por dolor literalmente nos
desintoxica moss
hace un par de años viví otro momento de
pico de loro emocional en mi vida
también entendiendo ese momento de pico
dolor emocional que así como tenemos un
umbral de dolor físico tenemos un umbral
de dolor emocional y a veces hacemos
pico
en ese momento de pico dolor emocional
me acerque a un amigo y espiritual
gabriel
gabriel me recomendó algo me dijo al
servicio y gabriel está loco como en
este momento de intenso dolor emocional
voy a poder hacer servicio
sin embargo mis mis ganas de estar bien
fueron mucho más grandes que mis dudas
le hice caso y salí a hacer servicio
ayude a cuanta gente pude en la calle
con quien me topaba
atendí a más de una persona en forma
gratuita
recuerdo a una mujer que atendía en ese
entonces
y cuyo marido se había se había ahorcado
y recuerdo haberle preguntado qué fue lo
que le dijeron a tu hijo de siete años
en cuanto a la causa de muerte en su
papá
esta mujer me respondió le dijimos que
murió del corazón
si este hombre había muerto del intenso
dolor del corazón y de ese pico de dolor
que hizo en un momento dado de su vida
la vida he aprendido que es como una
montaña rusa a veces estás arriba a
veces estás abajo en momentos oscilantes
y cambiantes de la vida la vida es
dualidad es alegría tristeza amor
desamor luz oscuridad día noche
inclusive la palabra chino la palabra
'crisis' en chino significa dos cosas
riesgo y oportunidad
de preocuparnos es la situación que
viven los jóvenes el día de hoy
que están cada día más conectados a sus
teléfonos ya sus redes sociales
tienen la posibilidad de tener todo de
forma inmediata al alcance de su mano se
pueden conectar con cualquier persona en
cualquier parte del mundo en cualquier
momento pueden pedir una pizza que
llegará en media hora
pueden comprar música sin siquiera haber
tenido que ir a la tienda a comprarla
estos chicos tienen muy baja tolerancia
a la frustración y cero capacidad de
demora que se refiere a esperar a que
las cosas sucedan ocurran
estos chicos con baja tolerancia a la
frustración no están preparados para
subirse a la montaña rusa de la vida y
no morir en el intento
los padres que me consultan sobre los
chicos a los padres que me consultan
sobre los chicos adolescentes sus hijos
adolescentes les digo que es importante
enseñarles la frustración amorosa
esto es decirles que no con amor si tú
que los amas les dices que no los estás
preparando para la vida la vida no es
justa la vida los va a frustrar no les
va a tocar el jefe que quieren no los
van a limitar a todas las fiestas tal
vez la novia los termine estos chicos
tienen que ir haciendo lo que yo llamo
callo emocional
este callo emocional es el que nos va a
proteger para la vida
me pregunto también en relación al dolor
qué podemos hacer y creo que podemos
darnos cuenta que todos funcionamos como
una red de contención
pero no nada más para nuestras personas
cercanas e inmediatas no nada más se
trata de mi madre de mi hermana de mi
novio de mi pareja de mis hijos somos
una red de contención social
todos podemos ayudar al otro que está
pasando por un momento de dolor
si hiciéramos verdaderamente esto
disminuye y disminuiría la estadística
de suicidio
tal vez
hace poco más de dos años
viví una experiencia que cambió mi vida
para siempre
era temprano en la mañana yo iba al
gimnasio después dejar a mis hijos de la
escuela iba tarde iba descalza muy mal
esto no se maneja es que al salida
descalza
cuando en una de las calles de playa del
carmen y la vuelta venía venía en la
carretera de la vuelta
y volvía al puente de un chico sentado
al borde del puente estuve a punto de
seguirme
algo dentro de mí mi intuición me dijo
para ti algo no está bien le dice acaso
la intuición me pare
y ahí en medio de la calle empecé a
gritarle no lo hagas tu vida es
importante para mí
una y otra y otra vez coches iban coches
venían nadie se paraba el tiempo se me
hizo eterno
finalmente
benjamín un chico repartidor de frutas y
verduras que estaba haciendo su trabajo
diario se paró se bajó y se unió a mi
súplica
ahí los dos en medio de la calle
seguimos gritando
cuando de repente vemos este chico
dar el paso descolgarse y quedar
colgado en el puente
benjamín y yo nos asustamos
horriblemente si iba en serio hasta ese
momento no teníamos la certeza que se
tratara de un intento de suicidio más
angustiados más asustados seguimos
gritando buscando ayuda desesperadamente
nadie se paraba me giré a la escena y
empecé a hacer las señales a una
patrulla que al que hace ver venir a lo
lejos en el momento que me giré
escucha mis espaldas al chico caixa
un segundo me quedé me quede congelada
imaginándome la escena que vería al
voltear
cuando finalmente volteé
vi al chico del puente en brazos de
benjamín benjamín había logrado cachar
este chico en el aire
me acerque
nos tomamos de las manos y comenzamos a
rezar ahí sin conocernos los tres
siquiera
llegó la patrulla llegó la ambulancia
movilicen sus coches
benjamín se sacude el pantalón así sin
más se parece fue
yo me quedé en estado de shock el resto
del día
tratando de entender que había vivido
sintiendo que la vida me está dando un
mensaje para ser compartido
finalmente me senté a escribir para mi
página de facebook
lo siguiente
me haya dado cuenta que les diga la
frase que benjamín no es un hombre alto
no es un hombre especialmente fuerte
benjamín había logrado salvar este chico
con solo su intención
y escribir la siguiente frase
perdón me brinqué una imagen
la intención es el viento que necesitan
tus alas
poco tiempo después salió esta noticia
en el periódico
mujer maravilla salvo a un hombre que se
tiró del puente
la noticia no era correcta y no era
correcta porque no se trata de
superhéroes o de mujeres maravilla se
trata de hombres y mujeres sensibles
conectados preocupados por los demás
mujeres como benjamín aquí presente
y hoy amigo benjamín se trata de hombres
y mujeres como benjamín o como mariah
que se detienen a su paso preocupados
por los demás pueden estar preocupados
por el niño que llora en la calle por el
taxista que tiene la cara nula de dolor
por la mujer que está siendo golpeada
por su marido
tú
puede ser en camino y no sólo puede ser
benjamín todos somos benjamín
para hacer como benjamín o como maria
sólo se requiere de una cosa tener la
intención de ayudar y decir tu vida es
importante para mí
[Aplausos]